feel actually real quick somebody got
you tatted on them dog are you serious
dead serious and I mean tatted is that
the evolved that Kevin baking melting oh
that's Kevin Bacon from hallow man and
touching there's a rat as a sidekick oh
my god that's beautiful first of all the
tattoo is good the guy did a great job
with the tattoo on that he got that
knows for sure bro can you quit talking
about my nose no you can I'd say me that
good sir sometime okay oh you have a
nice I started by your skin earlier dude
like that man yeah you said it was tan
it was nice I'm sorry I didn't call you
white my bad well what I'm saying is I
think I think they did a really accurate
job one yeah I think it's great it's
really really good work I wish I looked
better than that and regularly that's
the sad thing about a tattoo it's like
man damn that's how I look
portraits are tough corsets are tough
one eye down and it's game over yeah
game over your minds don't match I think
there's definitely somebody out there as
one of my eyes
I love the rat though right there huh
that rat is saucy yeah no that's a dope
tattoo right a saucy man oh wait and I
met the guy who did this for in
Disneyland actually I met the guy that
did does this tattoo I think really yeah
I can't believe I didn't see ya does he
do tattoos at Disneyland when was this
do you know it was yesterday Oh what if
it's still on my Instagram I could share
it does he do tattoos in the haunted
house what's going on here is that where
you met him do we know did it yeah he
the guy that he also is the driver on
the Jungle Cruise is he really I don't
know dude you're the one I met him at
Disneyland I'm Jamie
good night ideas up Jamie Lee Parker
Jamie Lee Parker dude first of all
sounds like somebody that's up shoot a
president Oh ink master c-section or has
a set of double d's and make pornos
Jamie what is it Jamie leave Jamie Lee
Parker they were on ink master season 11
I bet Kevin
Eakins thrill about it that's it's
really good work man
the coloring the shadings ridiculous is
that a calf yeah like that there's a
long tit I thought I thought someone's
neck I thought your boy long neck oh
dang I'll be crazy I thought long neck
so wild if you got that just you on the
side of the worst tattoo this is like
lick here is this pointing at like
someone whose chest the air is kind of
awful hey but of course yeah of course
that's true yeah that's what he would
have yeah that's dope what else is you
can put your whole family tree on Will
Sasso SCAF oh you put your mom brother
animals everything biggest cap I've ever
seen really oh my god that's big um cab
huh it's just a big dude yeah it's the
biggest friend we have dude how could
you wear that much yellow and just be
okay when you leave the hell
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]